[Música]
para las celebridades el primer lunes de
mayo sólo significa una cosa nueva york'
pasión el evento apodado el baile de la
moda volvió a su fecha tradicional en el
calendario
es maravilloso estar de vuelta estoy
feliz de ver a todo el mundo salir esta
noche
los más famosos buscaron que la noche
quedará para el recuerdo
algunos incluso hicieron que los fans
retrocedieran en el tiempo la estrella
de los realities kim kardashian logró
que las miradas se dirigieron hacia ella
en la alfombra roja luciendo el mismo
vestido que marilyn monroe llevó en 1962
cuando cantó el feliz cumpleaños al
fallecido ex presidente de eeuu john
f.kennedy
[Música]
kim kardashian perdió más de 7 kilos en
tres semanas para que el icónico vestido
le quedara el tema de la extravagancia
de la moda de este año fue la edad
dorada una época de finales de 1800
conocida por la prosperidad y la
opulencia y las personalidades de este
año no defraudaron con sus atuendos más
extravagantes pero el tema fue criticado
por alejarse de la realidad actual ya
que el evento tuvo lugar en un momento
en que muchos estadounidenses luchan
contra la creciente inflación y una
economía que coquetea con la recesión
sin embargo algunos famosos quisieron
destacar los problemas reales el alcalde
de nueva york puso la política en primer
plano con un esmoquin negro y un motivo
el cnd violence un mensaje contra las
armas quería aprovechar este momento
para hablar del incontable número de
personas inocentes que mueren a causa de
la violencia de las armas con entradas a
35 mil dólares cada una la gala anual
recauda sumas de 8 cifras para el
instituto del traje del museo
metropolitano de arte de nueva york el
año pasado recaudó más de 16,4 millones
de dólares